germany is bracing for a much tougher
pandemic lockdown set to begin in the
coming days
a soft lockdown imposed in early
november failed to cut infection rates
now the country faces hard choices as it
goes into
the holiday season let's go live to
german chancellor angela merkel's press
conference
she's just had a meeting with german
state leaders and is expected to
announce
an even tougher lockdown a surge in the
number of coronavirus deaths
has prompted her and the government to
take action let's listen
this is because the measures that we put
into place on the 2nd of november
have not been sufficient
for a while we were able to stop the
exponential growth
and had a plateau movement but now we
are seeing
a new rise in infections and exponential
growth once again
and what that means is that
many people are dying you'll have been
following the statistics i'm sure
and we also know that we are
close to exceeding the response capacity
of our public health
systems and our aim was always to
prevent
this and this is why
we must act and we must act fast and the
result
are the decisions that we made today the
aim
remains being able to trace
contacts once again so that means we
need an incidence
rate of 50 cases per 100 000 inhabitants
in a seven day period
and below now all of this will
impact on our holiday season as we are
well aware but we must act
and we will act
we have decided altogether that the
ordinances of the federal states will be
in place until the 10th of january
for now but the aim remains
to bring the incidence rate down
so what happens from early january
cannot be predicted now it will depend
on the results that we achieve with this
so we remain with our personal
contacts such that we can meet friends
and family members but a maximum of five
people
from two households at once
and this is only from the 24th until the
26th of december there will be an
exception
but not on new year's and not on new
year's eve
and so this means that above and beyond
your own household you
can invite for other people
in the holiday period from your closest
friends and families
your partners
direct relations so your parents
and your children and siblings
but we would like to appeal to all
citizens
if you're inviting other households over
for christmas
or other holidays please reduce your
contacts for
seven days before you do that so to have
a
protection week and then
from new year's afternoons there
will be no changes but from wednesday
the 16th of december we will be closing
retail apart from
essential goods retail
primarily food stores will not be
expanded and we are also putting a ban
on fireworks ahead of new year's eve and
there'll be an ordinance in place to
make this law
there will also be a ban on body care
services hairdressers beauty salons etc
schools will also be
limited and daycare centers as well
so that will mean that children are to
be looked
after at home wherever possible and from
the 16th of december so that's from
wednesday schools will be
closed certainly the school children no
longer have to go to school there will
be emergency care
in place for some children
and distance learning will also be
offered
the senior years of high school
might be dealt with differently and
daycare
will be run just the same as schools in
this regard we
are appealing to employers
to offer home office options
wherever possible from the 16th of
december until the 10th
of june
in terms of takeaway and delivery food
from restaurants this will continue to
be possible
but you are no longer allowed to eat
your takeaway
near or at the restaurant you will know
that in
recent days and weeks we have
again and again had a situation in which
there have been groups of people meeting
just
outside of cafes and restaurants
and they have been able to eat their
food just outside it
religious services will only be possible
under
strict constraints and we will be
speaking
with the churches and other
religious institutions we will be
focusing as well
on senior citizens homes
and homes for the very elderly there
will be mobile care services as well and
they will be getting
rapid tests as well we would
ask you to refrain from traveling abroad
if not absolutely necessary and the
quarantine
regulations will remain in place there
will be
economic support and the minister will
say more about that in a moment and
we've put together
a package of measures as well
which ensures that people are
compensated for the difficulties they'll
be experiencing
in their livelihood we are calling on
everyone to reduce
their contacts because wherever they can
and i want to thank
everyone in germany who has adhered to
these rules and regulations which you
have done to a large extent and i'd like
to urgently appeal to you
in the next days and weeks to avoid
contacts that aren't
absolutely necessary and by doing so to
contributing to
not exceeding the response capacity of
our public health systems and
those who work in hospitals the
physicians the care
geriatric care is the nurses i want to
thank all of you
because for you this is going to be a
very difficult holiday
season and we are
putting these efforts in place to
support you as well as
helping everyone stay well thank you
very much
[Music]
days and weeks there has been a process
of reaching an agreement between the
federal states and the national
government
and as the chancellor has just said
these
are tough measures for
nearly everyone they're tough for
families they're tough
for school children they're tough for
retail
and for many companies for the cultural
sector who still have no idea of
how things can proceed from here this is
a comprehensive
decision that we have agreed on
for myself i would just like to say a
bit about
my take on the situation
and to look back over the last few
months because in recent
days i've read again and again why now
why not a harder lockdown why can't
politicians agree on this that or the
other thing
if you look at what's been happening
since february and in march
in all of the federal states of germany
we have to say that we have responded
quickly
all of the state premiers have we have
restricted things we have closed things
from one day to the next
things that everyone took for granted
was suddenly not possible anymore
and we okay well angela merkel has been
leading with the 16 state leaders that
meeting has uh
ended we go live now to our political
correspondent hans brunt who is standing
by
hunts a lot to digest there what did you
make of it
well um there was at the moment as far
as i can see no surprise and what angela
mackel and her colleagues have now
announced or are busy announcing at the
moment in the chancellery that you see
behind me
the restrictions that had been agreed on
in a discussion paper
were it seems passed without too much
discussion
that's unusual for this kind of meeting
in the past these meetings since uh
sometime around october
have been very acrimonious and have
taken many many hours
for agreement to be reached so today
they have decided that there will be a
lockdown from
the 16th of december in other words this
coming wednesday
that retail shops will then be closed
except those shops
that sell essential goods that other
institutions such as schools will be
sent into
home schooling into distance learning
that companies are encouraged to give
their
employees off from that time across the
christmas period
or to also allow them to work at home
also closed will be hairdressers and
other
shops or other services that involve
very direct personal contact and they
have also imposed
a ban on the consumption of alcohol in
public spaces
and the use of fireworks around new year
so that's a whole gamut to try and
restrict the number of people that
gather
in public in private there will be a
restriction on five people
from two households that are allowed to
meet around christmas time that is
going to be uh loosened slightly it will
be five people but it does not need to
be only two households
yeah hence the wider holiday season will
change significantly this year from the
16th those changes come in
um another point up for discussion is
how that will affect
business merkel and state leaders also
discussed i believe compensation
yes indeed compensation was a central
part of this agreement that has now been
reached between the central government
and the
16 regional states and one is talking
about uh
an expense of somewhere around 10 or 12
billion euros every month in order to
compensate all the businesses
and all the and um
all the people who work for work for
themselves who work independently who
also can be compensated
um this amount of money has already been
spent in the last couple of months and
there has been some dispute between
central government
and the regions as to who is going to
carry uh
what part of that load so far it's been
central government that has paid most of
the money and there has been some
dissatisfaction amongst politicians here
in berlin
that the regions are not taking enough
share for themselves
at the moment it continues to be the
case that it is central government that
will pay
most of these 12 10 to 12 billion euros
every month
how exactly is going to be allocated is
this little a bit open yet
because until now the compensation that
has been paid in the last couple of
months has in some cases been too
generous
some restaurants for instance have been
doing better under lockdown than they
would have if they had been running
the details many details to follow hans
for your input thank you very much dwa
political correspondent hans brunt
you